[Music]
welcome to the heavy spoilers show i'm
your host paul aka the spoiler supreme
and in this video we're going to be
breaking down everything that episode 5
of what if entrails it's filled with
easter eggs hidden details and nods to
the marvel comic zombie series so sit
back shut up and come with us as we go
through it all if you haven't had a
chance to check it out then watching
past this point would be a great mistake
as there will be heavy heavy spoilers if
you enjoyed the video then please smash
the thumbs up button and use your brains
to make sure you never miss a video by
subscribing to the channel without the
way it's nice to eat you now let's get
into episode 5 of marvel's what if
okay so after last week's doctor strange
in the multiverse of sadness what if has
returned with one of the best episodes
in the series so far that plays upon the
long-running comic series marvel zombies
the entry reimagines how it would play
out in the mcu and it's got loads of
cool twists and turns in it now what a
zombie's favorite shampoo
head and shoulders say it's an oldie but
a goodie now we open at the start of
infinity war namely when hulk was
transported through the bifrost to the
sanctum sanctorum whereas originally he
came face to face with dr strange and
wong at this point he finds the world
completely different to how he left it
the shots in this moment perfectly
recapture the look of what happened in
that film and he watches the camera not
only spins over the new york skyline but
it also brings focus to the window at
the top of the building bruce crashes
through the stairs much like how he did
in that film but strange isn't there and
we now know that wong never got that
tuna melt now i love how much this looks
like the film and bruce says thanos is
coming repeatedly which is of course
what he uttered in the movie this
actually also foreshadows the end of the
episode and yeah what a way to set up
that big cliffhanger early on now it is
possible that the reason the sanctorum
and the no way home trailer is covered
in snow is because bruce crashed through
the roof and then both wong and strange
were dusted i like how that action is
sort of repeated here and he cries out
for some clothes which is when we get
our first look at strange's cape who
becomes a big character in the entry now
bruce ends up grabbing one of the
sorcerer gobs and he didn't have to do
this originally because he was given a
suit by strange and wong i always
wondered whether bruce's jacket was
actually the one that strange was
wearing when he went down the stairs so
if you're a jacket connoisseur then this
is your time to shine in the comments
now bruce leaves the sanctum of
sanctorum and we see bleecker street
completely abandoned this is of course
the opposite to how it was in infinity
war as everyone was rushing around as
the big donut ship hovered above the
city
donut ship that's the kind of info you
get here now both ebony moore and cull
obsidian then drop down and the
teleportation perfectly recaptures the
scene from iw in which they landed in
the street bruce tries to hulk out but
he's having performance issues and this
of course mirrors what happened in
infinity war luckily this time banner
isn't embarrassing anyone in front of
the wizard but hulk still isn't much
help now in the comics the hulk was a
zombie that helped to eat magneto but
upon turning back into bruce his stomach
was too small to digest him and he split
wide open bruce tried to turn back to
the hulk at several points but he was
unable to do it so i appreciate how
they've managed to tie in the mcu with
the source material now several of these
lines here are pulled directly from
infinity war including more saying hear
me and rejoice you are about to die at
the hands of the children of thanos hulk
also says no to which bruce says what do
you mean no which is another moment
that's ripped right out of the movie now
just as he's about to monologue a ball
appears behind moore's head and in pops
tony's repulsor blaster the iconography
of the three walking through the portal
of course plays upon when black panther
and co entered the battle at the end of
end game and we quickly learn exactly
why the streets are so empty we are
supposed to initially believe that this
is gonna be a scene similar to the
portals one but they spoiled it in the
marketing and let us know that it was
zombies ahead of time but if you didn't
say that big surprise now the avengers
go into full overkill mode and we see
how fast the virus works when obsidian
and more are instantly turned tony turns
round to reveal his face and the idea of
a zombie tony was first tended out and
far from home during the mysterio
illusion scene it's a great moment and i
don't know if i'm reading into it too
much here but i got a lot of flashes of
the first zombie reveal from resident
evil as the turn and growl are very
similar
what do you call a zombie version of
ebony more ebony nor
[Music]
now the ghouls turn their attention to
bruce but luckily he's saved by the cape
and a couple of familiar faces we see
that all the undead still have their
powers including wong who ends up
beheaded by his own portal something
similar of course happened in infinity
war when he used his portal as a way to
chop off cull obsidian's hand hoping
spider-man arrive and it's at this point
that we learn exactly what happened for
the virus to be born mirroring the
events of ant-man in the wasp hank
journeyed into the quantum realm in
order to find his wife janet turns out
that janet had contracted a quantum
virus that corrupted her brain and she
started to feast upon him when he
arrived this is actually a nod to the
comics as in that the virus came through
a hero from another dimension they
landed on earth and quickly started
infecting everyone and this is somewhat
mirrored when janet and hank return from
the quantum realm and unleash hell
whereas in ant-man and the wasp we got a
nice family reunion we see the pair lash
out and attack scott he slams his hand
against the glass in the lab and this
idea of hands pressing against glass and
zombie franchises has appeared in a lot
of films over the years and also games
like the left 4 dead series it could
also be a naughty titanic and i believe
that the head does go on hey having that
is really bad now as we touched on
earlier the episode is based heavily on
the marvel zombies comic series i'm
going to be doing a quick breakdown of
the first graphic novel of that so we
can see some of the similarities here
and also the differences however if you
don't hear me rambling then time codes
will be linked below but i absolutely
love this run and it's probably the only
time that i'm ever going to be able to
talk about it in a video written by the
walking dead's robert kirkman we pick up
in the aftermath of a zombie plague that
has wiped out most of humanity brought
in from another dimension this disease
pretty much keeps those that it infects
relatively intelligent though they now
hunger for human flesh we open with one
of the survivors magneto running through
a city as he's chased by the undead he
actually manages to cut off the top half
of captain america's head by using his
shield against him and he of course
appears in this episode a big difference
though is that spider-man is one of the
undead for the whole story and there's a
running joke throughout it that his leg
is pretty much hanging on by a thread we
also discover that he ate his own wife
and and may and he's one of the funniest
characters in it yeah no it doesn't
sound that funny but it is when you read
the book just trust me now at one point
we discovered that t'challa is actually
being kept alive by a zombified hank pym
and he's been sedated so that hank and
him slowly this of course happens later
on in the episode but i'll touch upon
that more as we get to that bit one of
the big problems that the undead have is
that they're constantly famished and as
the arc goes on we watch them traveling
through the universe eating absolutely
everything hank's wife janet discovers
t'challa and wants some of him too but
he bites her head off before trying to
cover it up t'challa eventually escapes
with janet and he travels into space
with some survivors who've been living
on a satellite in order to avoid the
plague that has ravaged mankind during
the book the silver surfer arrives and
brings forth galactus which leads to a
big showdown between him and the undead
there's such a good moment where
wolverine tries to cut the surfer but
because his flesh is decomposing his
claws hitting against his skin just
cracks his arm wide open the zombies end
up winning and after consuming galactus
they become a group known as galacti
they head out into the universe
consuming all and five years later we
watch as t'challa travels back to earth
with janet pym we realize that the
hunger eventually passes if you don't
feed for so long and in the ruins of the
planet they create new wakanda now the
second book picks up on this story and
it questions whether t'challa is fit to
reign and also has him become a zombie
himself the main ones of course return
to earth and it's a really fun read that
i don't want to spoil too much as i'll
be here forever but yeah definitely
check it out if you've enjoyed this
episode and what i've been saying so far
marvel zombies also appeared in 2015
secret wars and if the rumors of that
story popping up in the mcu are true
then it's something that you should
definitely get you're dead around now
from here we watch how it spreads from
san francisco and this is of course the
city in which ant-man and the wasp took
place though the avengers arrived to
save the day a tiny hank ended up
turning them and having super powered
people amongst their ranks just helped
the plague to spread even faster kurt
dipita making a home video on how to
survive the zombie apocalypse and this
is very similar to the rules for
surviving zombieland which opened up
that film this video of course pulls
from the start of homecoming and whereas
in that opening peter started it by
saying queens here he introduces us to
new york home of the zombie apocalypse
happy hogan ends up getting used as a
prop and i think it's hilarious that his
t-shirt says he's saving himself for
thought i thought this might kind of
foreshadow that he'd get eaten by him
but at this point thor was of course in
space now his skills also include
driving because he was tony chauffeur as
well as boxing in iron man 2 we watched
him training tony to box and this was a
nod to the comics as the character was a
boxer in them here we meet another mcu
mainstay aka kurt who you might know
from the ant-man franchise he's wearing
an x-con security jacket and this was of
course the company that he and his
friends set up in that movie his skills
include languages because he speaks many
islamic folklore because he's constantly
going on about baba yaga and crime
because well the guy was a burglar now
we can also see that under his name is
resident weirdo which might be a play on
resident evil though that might be a
reach now happy wears one of iron man's
gloves and we saw him pull this out in
civil war when facing off against bucky
for the first time peter does a great
job of explaining the rules and we see
bucky whose skills include murder killer
arm and what my wife calls me when i
have a nap now next we meet sharon
carter aka the bloody power broker and
her nickname is the blonde bond aka bond
james bond really the nickname the
blonde bond was actually given to daniel
craig as he was the first james bond
actor that was blonde her skills include
spycraft first aid and eulogies because
she of course spoke at her and peggy's
funeral next we meet akoye who has
arrived to find out what happened to
t'challa we learn that she's travelled
from wakanda and because the heroes
aren't there to stop thanos he arrives
on the planet to get the mine stone but
is quickly swamped by the zombies now we
see that the heroes are hiding in train
cars suspended above buildings and i
don't know how the zombies didn't get
them as tony can fly but never mind now
this might actually be paying tribute to
the original sam raimi spider-man
trailer which was released before
september 11th spider-man ended up
stopping a bank robbery and he strung up
the character's helicopter between the
two iconic landmarks the trailer was
taken out of rotation after that tragedy
and though it might not be intentional
the imagery here did remind me a lot of
that i'm not trying to offend anyone
there as we are coming up to the 20th
anniversary and i just thought i'd
mention it due to the similarities now
we learned that progress has been made
on a cure and this is located at camp
lehigh which you will know as being the
place that captain america trained at
and it's also where shield first set up
their operations after changing from the
ssr i know i keep saying which you will
know as i like to give you credit too
for stuff even if you don't know it and
remember yeah the thumbs up buttons
right there now they travel across the
bridge on the lead up to central station
and this was of course an iconic
location that appeared in the avengers
movie during their team at moment
traveling in miniature mode they're
shocked by a big zombie and the van of
course also did this in ant-man and the
wasp okay drops a sick burn and says
wakanda doesn't need horror movies
because they have american reality tv
shows maybe you should have watched them
horror movies a and you wouldn't got to
that point now she wants to split up
which is something you should never do
in a zombie apocalypse and peter
correctly guesses that this is a bad
idea happy [ __ ] up his arm much like a
shotgun and this is because of the glove
but a shotgun is of course a weapon
that's often used in zombie films at
this point falcon begins his attack on
the group and we see that he unleashes a
murder of crows in the comics falcon can
actually telepathically communicate with
birds and he's brought along hawk i2 hey
nice little pun that now the fight to
central station is awesome and sharon
ends up using happy's glove against him
as akoye cuts falcon in half i think
it's hilarious out after this happened
that bucky isn't that upset and it just
kind of comments on the relationship
that the pair have in the subway peter
tries to pull the train onto the track
and he's attacked by the undead but
luckily the cape swoops in to save the
day and it becomes very much one of
their closest allies throughout the
episode they head out to lehigh however
it's not all train sailing and zombie
cap arrives and attacks their ride he
gives sharon a love bite that's way
worse than what they were doing in civil
war
even though yeah she is your niece mate
and that's a bit gross now he and bucky
go head to head in a scene that mirrors
the fight in the winter soldier and it's
a brilliant action moment i think it's
hilarious that bucky decapitates him and
says guess this is the end of the line
and i'm with you till the end of the
line was of course a saying that the two
said to cement their friendship hope
flies in sharon's mouth and bursts her
open from the inside and we see that she
got scratched a main character getting
infected and then worrying that they
might turn is of course a trout that has
showed up in several zombie films
however peter says that she represents
hope for the cure and i love how the
episode changes from an action-packed
zombie shootout into an emotional
introspective look at how peter has lost
a lot but that he keeps smiling he
utters similar words to what cap did an
endgame namely that they have to keep
going now this speech is very important
as i believe it's the first time that
uncle ben has been acknowledged by name
in the mcu he has been absent throughout
outside of a briefcase with his initials
on but i'm glad they're finally really
referencing the character the train
comes to a stop and the heroes realize
that the only way to get to the camp is
by moving through a zombie horde hope
very much blames herself for bringing
janet back and she grows gigantic in
order to transport them across the field
the sun's getting real low as we head
into the final act and it's an emotional
goodbye for her as she tells peter to
smile before being swamped by the undead
bucky realizes that at the camp they
aren't attacking or swarming them and we
come face to face with vision who has
made his home inside arnhem zola's brain
turns out the mind stone or rather its
ability to control people's
consciousness is something that is the
key to reversing things we see that
scott is a head in a jar similar to the
ones from futurama and beyond this it's
actually a pretty deeply layered easter
egg in the comics it was of course janet
who was the beheaded one that ended up
becoming an ally and in the zombie movie
reanimator we watched as a head was
brought back to life scott dropped some
zombie puns that really put him ahead of
me in terms of comedy and we learn that
they need access to a satellite network
which may be a nod to how the heroes
survived in the comics they make a plan
to journey to wakanda which of course
also appeared in the source material as
a haven and bucky learns that vision has
went a bit ultron and that he's been
feeding people to wonder similar to the
graphic novel bucky comes across
t'challa with his leg cut off and we
also discover scarlet witch is being fed
the heroes that arrived there much like
one day in one division
has went too far in attempting to bring
her back and he's willing to sacrifice
anyone to keep her alive until he
manages to cure her it leads to an
awesome final act in which the avengers
face off against a zombie fight scarlet
witch and after realizing what he's done
vision decides to help the heroes scott
ends up becoming buddies with the cape
and he shouts wingardium leviosa which
you might know well you might i don't
know you you might know as being the
levitation spell from the harry potter
series vision rips out the mind stone
similar to what thanos did to him and
you might notice that his body turns
grey upon this happening which is of
course another thing that happened in
infinity war he gives them the mind
stone but the undead realizing that he's
destroyed start to storm the camp and
bucky buys them time against the witch
she's devastated her love is gone and
angered at his death she throws bucky
away which i really hope that he
survived scarlet witch blocking the
bullets could also be a nod to one
division namely when a son did the same
thing now we get a similar moment to the
heroes returning to the hangar in civil
war and the witch flies to bruce to bite
him but he beats her back bruce
sacrifices himself and whereas the hulk
has refused to come out at this point in
the episode he finally hulks up to
answer the question of who would win
between him and scholar witch now it's
at this point i realized that peter
parker hadn't been wearing his mask at
all because everyone was dead and he
didn't need to hide his identity just
just a little bit of trivia there the
heroes escape but as they fly out hope
resurrects and grabs the quinjet really
nice little setup and payoff to which
scott is of course gutted about and this
idea of hope once more carries them
forward as they travel across the skies
zombie movies ending with survivors
flying out was a trope that was started
all the way back in the dawn of the dead
and we get a very punient speech from
t'challa in which he says death is not
the end sadly chadwick boseman who
played him passed away and this moment
holds even more weight knowing what
happened now they arrive at wakanda but
we see that there's now a zombie thanos
there and all that he needs is the mind
stone they've just brought that and it's
a great cliffhanger that i really hope
we get to see the outcome of sooner
rather than later
now as for my thoughts on the episode as
i'm sure you can guess i really enjoyed
it and this feels like another great
what if i think that this might even be
the episode that people show newcomers
to say look it is a good show and
overall yeah lots to take from this
according to the report this week was
actually supposed to be the party thor
one but for whatever reason i changed it
to this and i'm so glad that they did
whether the leaks were wrong whether
this was always meant to be the case or
whether marvel looked at the leaks and
thought yeah let's just shuffle it up i
really don't know but this was such a
nice change of pace from what i was
expecting what i love about whatif is
that one week you can be seeing the
origin story for a character the next
you can be having a fun ride through the
galaxy and whether it's a murder mystery
or an introspective look at what lost
can do to a person what if really has it
all i know there's a lot that aren't
vibing with the series as i read
comments on it every week but as someone
who's on board with what they're doing i
have to say i've been really enjoying it
i think it's very much a case of
personal taste and i know some that have
loved an episode one week and hated the
next one which can lead to things
feeling very up in the air i actually do
enjoy all of them except for maybe the
twist in the third which i had some
issues with however for me it's doing
way more good than it is bad the comic
did a great job of keeping this
aesthetic going and making it crazier
and crazier so i'd love to revisit this
universe over and over again now
following on from our leaks part of the
video last week we have some brand new
reports on doctor strange in the
multiverse of madness that time to what
if i will be discussing some spoilers so
if you don't want anything ruined then i
recommend that you check out of the
video and thank you for sticking with me
for this long don't forget to hit the
thumbs up button on the way out and i
hope you enjoy the rest of your day
there you go what a bunch of losers they
were
coming to a channel called heavy
spoilers and don't want spoilers
never mind now last week after doctor
strange supreme arrived on the scene i
put out a video saying i'd love to see
the character in live-action form during
the multiverse of madness i kind of went
off into a fan theory tangent and talked
about why i thought it was the true true
villain of the movie which yeah we know
i'm good at guessing them and i just
think that would be absolutely amazing
to see in this film the world will
forget that i said matt murdock was in
the no way home trailer and that
mephisto was behind it all however it
looks like he might actually be showing
up in the movie and scuba daniel rpk put
out a post saying that he will indeed be
dropping in on the multiverse of madness
evidence to support this or rather the
lack of has been unearthed when pouring
over old images in interviews at the
time of filming in the multiverse of
madness benedict did a chat over zoom
but he hid his face during the entire
interview so that people couldn't get a
good look at him let's play the clip and
by the way you're looking at a ceiling
because i can't show you my face because
i'm filming doctor strange and it's all
embargoed what i look like anyway
just to explain why you're looking at a
very attractive ceiling in the trailer
now very suspicious i think that had
come on screen and just had the whole
just turned into a sith lord look then
it would be pretty obvious by now
exactly what had happened so it's
probably for the best that he stayed out
the way now i also must say that this
doesn't confirm anything and the guy
might have just had a cold sore but it
does make a lot of sense that strange
supreme would be in the film we are of
course dealing with the multiverse and
him coming face to face with the darker
version of himself would be absolutely
brilliant might also explain who has
wander's kids captive and if he had
access to the library of cagliastro then
he could have also gained a version of
the darkhold and have spoken to her
through that that's all theoretical at
the moment but with rumors of captain
carter also appearing in the film i
think what if is becoming a series that
people definitely need to stay locked
into anyway i'd love to hear whether you
think it's doctor strange supreme or if
you think it's a cold sore and that he
should go see the doctors hey the
comment section is yours to write
whatever you like and i'd love to hear
your thoughts on the episode as well we
are running a competition right now and
giving away three copies of the zack
snyder dc trilogy on the 30th of
september and all you have to do to be
on the chance of winning is like the
video make sure you subscribe with
notifications on and drop a comment
below with your thoughts on the episode
we picked the comments at random at the
end of the month and the winners of the
last one on screen right now so message
me on twitter heavyspoilers if that's
you if you want something else to watch
then make sure you check out breakdown
of the rick and morty finale which will
be linked on screen right now we pointed
out all the easter eggs we could find in
episode 9 and 10 and it's definitely
worth checking out as it's one of our
better works which isn't tough let's be
honest if not then thank you for sitting
through the video i've been paul i'll
see you next time take care peace